a husband and wife from south carolina
claim they're being held
captive in the british virgin islands
lynn and john hines say they were taken
into custody in mid-november
after accidentally sailing too close to
shore
the british virgin islands has
prohibited u.s visitors during the
pandemic
meg oliver spoke to the couple now in a
government-mandated 14-day quarantine
this is the hotel in the british virgin
islands where lynn and john hines say
they've been
forced to stay for almost two weeks how
uncomfortable is it living there
extremely uncomfortable we've asked if
they could
spray for bugs and they just ignored our
request
the couple says they along with a friend
and boat captain
were detained after their ship
accidentally veered into the territory
he immediately turned the vessel around
but before we got back to the waters
the british virgin islands
came up upon us and they said you need
to drop your sails
and you need to follow us the british
virgin islands has banned u.s citizens
because of the coronavirus
in a statement the local government said
the persons were charged with illegal
entry without the permission of an
immigration officer
but the couple says they've yet to hear
that from customs or immigration
officials
nobody would tell us why we were here
and to this day we still don't know
did you know there was a travel advisory
banning americans
we knew that the borders were closed but
i had no idea about territorial waters
michael winkelmann is an expert in
maritime law
it's really kind of absurd because if
you if you're at all familiar with this
geography
it's literally an invisible border it's
not like there's signs in the middle of
the ocean that says
you're crossing over from one territory
to the next the couple says they are now
awaiting cova tests before they can have
their day
in court we want out we want to go home
we did nothing
wrong the captain has said he takes
total responsibility
and to hold us here hostage like this
we're just a bargaining chip we can't
understand why they were doing this
for cbs this morning meg oliver new york